hello everyone welcome to a very nice
game from the penultimate round of the
LT box no way championships the game
just ended so I thought why not just
make a video on it you know right away
it's Magnus cross and vs. you and ye and
both of them have had a lot of success
in the Hindi Armageddon's throughout
this whole Norway event so we'll see how
their their matchup will turn out again
I will not mention if this is a
classical or Armageddon and I will just
let you decide it's it's quite an
exciting game and also we do have a nice
photo of this matchup
courtesy of Leonard Otis official
photographer the OtterBox Norway
championship there you have it Magnus
and youngji and the I don't know who the
gentleman is making the first move for
Magnus but judging by the t-shirt it's
obviously someone who is doing something
for for a phone Doran so that being said
let's check out this very nice game
crossing with the white pieces opens
with d4 we have d5 c4 and c6 the Slav
defense is on the board Knight to f3
with knife to f6 and now knife to c3 and
now young he captures on c4 with efore
by Carson may be preparing e5 and now
comes b5 defending the c4 pawn so Magnus
is unable to recapture immediately and
now asking Magnus what do you want to do
here Crossin continues Bishop to e2 he
just prepares the castle and here yongi
doesn't go for the for the most obvious
idea but he goes for B for attacking the
knight immediately trying to get rid of
the defender of the e4 and it's only
move 6 but there are very few games that
have actually been played that have
reached this position I think around 14
and here Crossing plays d5 and now what
do you do
the knight is under attack of course you
don't want to move this Knight and lose
d4 pawn so cross and just advances it
and here there are two games in the
database where Knight to d5 was played
but here B captures on c3 is a new move
so already has removed 7 yoo-jung he
goes into uncharted territory so what
does Crossing do of course he wants to
recapture the piece with it captures on
f6
now young he has to decide that does he
want to go for this captures captures
and captures like this where Carson will
have an isolated deep on or for the line
that he chose he first captures on e6
and after Carlson captured at BC three
he then went Bishop to d6 so quickens
the development but it also strengthens
constant center now of course you
noticed that young he has a CC pawn so
one thing you would definitely want to
do is play c5 here just get rid of your
CC pawn and then you pretty much you you
know you're good to go
the problem is if you play something
like this then after Bishop captures on
c4 you don't really have an option of
capturing here because after Knight
captures there's no good way to develop
your King will just be stuck in the
center for example if you play something
like there should be seven Queen f3 just
picks up the rook you know there's
there's no way around it
so Bishop to d6 you will have to suffer
with your well not suffer but you will
have to endure your CC pawn for the
moment we have castles by cross and
castles by yongi and now Knight to D -
I'm going after the c4 pawn with the
night and then from there and Knight
will also target the bishop we have
worked it eh by yongi rook to e1 by
Magnus and not Knight to d7 getting this
Knight over to b6 to help out with the
defense of the c4 pawn and only now this
Magnus capture with Knight captures on
c4 and now Bishop to Cecil not allowing
this straight of course and Bishop to f3
causing grabs hold of this beautiful
diagonal and like we mentioned you know
it'd be great if you could get rid of
this this well isolated pawn but for a
moment it's not possible as the rook is
hanging on a eight so what do you do
here first Bishop to e6 attacking the
knight here that is undefended Magnus
brings it back to e3
and now comes Knights the b6 and here
again now what do you do you you for the
moment you still can't capture if you
capture than just Queen D sex with a
double attack attack is the bishop ndh
to point you're going to lose a piece
here so after night that b6 we have Bush
up to a3 by Magnus there's no rush in
capturing this and here we have Knight
to c4 so what do you do here
here cross and has the option of
actually capturing now because after
Bishop captures yes black will capture
on a3 but now you get the Queen to a4
and you get this crazy position where
the rook is under attack the bishop is
under attack the knight is under attack
and here black would go for Bishop to b5
and after captures here then you would
play Bishop captures on h2
King captures and now Queen to beat
check will now pick up the Bishop Kings
you want now comes Knight capture some
b5 and you get this position with equal
material on the board but Magnus would
have three point islands and the King's
position would be someone loosened and
black would have two point islands with
only one isolated upon on the ante a
file crossing decides against this and
he goes to Queen to d3 which seems like
an odd decision you know placing your
Queen in front of the bishop like this
but the bishop is undefended so if the
knight moves Magnus wants to pick up the
bishop that's his plan now there's a
double attack against the night here so
what do you do here young e finds a very
nice idea rook captures on e3 so what do
you do obviously you can capture with
the rook or with the pawn if you capture
with the pawn you get to this line
Knight captures on a3 and after Queen
captures on a six-night the c2 chair and
not check but you know forking the rooks
and after something rook and Knight
captures rook captures and you would get
this position where it's it's not not a
bad position you have this massive
Center here but cousin prefers the
position with the pawn on f2 so he
decides for a different line he goes
rook captures on e3 Knight captures on
e3 and now Queen captures on a six hour
but black still gets his night to c2 in
attacking the bishop and the rook rook
to d1 and only now Knight captures on a3
with Queen captures on a3 and this is
the position Magnus prefers there's
still this pressure here still unable to
push c5 and it will be hard to hard to
get out of this if Carson just captures
here well not for the moment as you
still don't want to run into any tricks
but the Queen is guarding d6 so it's not
really an issue here if you go Bishop d6
try and kick away Magnus is queen he'll
just gonna have a queen a 4 with a
double attack here also putting pressure
on a7 so you can't really go rook c8 and
after Queen c7 just
g3 defend BH to pawn and still black
will have a very hard time defending
this so after Queen to a3 yongi played
Queen to b6 he says okay let's trade
Queens and then maybe I'll be down on a
pawn after you after you capture it but
at least it's a bishop of opposite color
same game and you know I will hold this
to a draw Magnus says all right then
with Sora queen capture somebody 6 but
shuttle captures and now the problem is
if you capture this bishop at this point
here with the bishop you get rook c8 now
if you move the bishop you lose the c2
response you have to play d5 but then
after Ruby 8 yes it's a nice structure
here but this bishop is now basically a
pawn and you will it's very unlikely
that you will get this point all the way
to c5 so not the best way to treat this
position but you know you're at home
having a lovely time feel free to pause
the video and try the best try to find
the best idea here for white while I
have a nice sip of my water for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are truly a master
of opposite color Bishop end games and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
the show here at Magnus played c4 and
now you see the problem now there won't
be a there there won't be an issue
c5 is coming which comes with an attack
on the bishop here and only then will
you recapture here and then there's no
no problem of route coming to c8
so here yongi takes advantage of this c4
move to get rid of the pin rook c8 now
the pawn is guarded but here Magnus just
plays c5 with Bishop d7
and here a constants plan is next he now
wants to play king of one king he to
king d3 king to c4 get the King all the
way here and then at some point
well if possible get the rook all the
way up there and well it was somehow
wind the c6 pawn and pushed these pawns
to victory so let's see let's see if
that is possible
he starts with King f1 of course with f5
by youngji and King t2 so the King March
is happening with g5 preparing g4 so
first the magnets blocks with h3 King to
g7 black also wants to get the King into
the game and now King to d3
we have kinked the g6 and now look the
b1 the rook will now infiltrate the
seventh rank via rook to b7 with h5 by
black and now rook to b7 so already
attacking the a 7-point and the bishop
here with rush up to f6 now with ideas
that if white starts any quick pawn
grabbing then you get a rope here and
then it will be a problem defending the
d4 pawn so here rook the d7 Carson
doesn't allow rook to b8 and now g4 by
black cross and ignores this with Bush
of 2 d1 says ok if you want to capture
you can capture and now King to g5 black
brings the King deeper into the game and
now again if you play something like
capture 0 capture series just gonna get
Ruby d8 it comes with an attack on the
pawn here and even after h4 of course
King g6 will be played you will have to
work c7 and then you will lose this pawn
here so you cannot allow rook to d8 here
cross someplace Bishop to a4 again just
putting pressure on the c6 pawn with f4
by black and now comes f3 preparing to
capture here or let maybe black can
capture it doesn't really matter but
both of it works works a nicely in white
favor with rook to e8 black now grabs
hold of the e3 square so he wants to
gain activity with the rook as well with
F captures H captures H captures and now
rook to e6 keeping an eye on the c6 pawn
but now Magnus just retreats best of the
d1 and now he guards the g4 pawn so all
in all he went upon and now he just
continues with his plan with rook to e3
with check King to c4 finally the King
reaches the destination and now a5 with
Bishop to f3 now it's no longer possible
to defend the c6 pawn and now rook to a3
going after the a to pawn Bishop
captures on c6 with rook captures an a2
and now Russia back to e for controlling
the C 2 square so no rook to c2 check
will be possible with a for yongi also
starts pushing his passport but now
comes c6 we have looked to a 1 now
checks
with c1r possible but just c7 with a
three and here of course you don't want
to play c8 with Queen because then you
would just lose that Queen after rook
captures on c8 but here after a three
cross and just played King Tubby three
not allowing rook to see one check and
it was in fact in this position that
yongi resigned the game as there is
nothing to do here whatever you play
let's say play rook the c1 Magnus will
just block it with the bishop and next
movie will bring a queen into the game
even if a2 it is possible black can
continue the game but then you just
streaming over the rook rook d5 check
King to h4 and now you get to rope the
a5 preventing any any sneaky tricks from
black and after a one Queen you will
seem to trade trade bring your Queen
into the game and now you'll have a
queen in Bishop against Bishop and rook
of course a completely winning game for
white so you don't you of course
calculated all of this after King b3 he
said thank you I've had I've had enough
and he resigned the game so that being
said now I will mention it this was a
game from the classical time format and
so two full points for Magnus crossing
which means that now short spoiler for
those of you who are not interested in
the results maybe skip some 30 seconds
Magnus Carlsen is the 2019 LT box Norway
championship winner with one round to
spare in round nine he faces Fabiana
karana with the black pieces but he can
lose tomorrow and he will still win the
ottomans Norway championship so pretty
much tomorrow he faces Cora wanna just
just for the for the rating and you know
for for glory but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoy it
really an astounding performance by
world champion Magnus Carlsen I would
like to thank Robert Baker forest roads
rough Al Gore how Bracker my knee and a
message for contributed to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video see her thank you for watching and
I will see you soon
most likely with another game from round
8 and then tomorrow we are you know
finishing this championship with round 9
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day